what's going on down there puszi lead pass on
the be of ycro who was in behind the floor to
the F from a sharp angle ycro shoots rebound and
pzi turn another chance loock bad news he's got
no goals yet but he's out there physical trying
to get play going and he has a good opportunity
with his line yard cro puts it at the front
of the net tight angle bangs around do gets
a rebounder chance and then the benw on Tim
but ball around for Riley picked up now by
Nick Robertson his pocket pick by mon je up
a centering pass kied away from gagovic Jonah
gagovic from Whit was parked on the front door
monter shoots ball punches man away and stenin
couldn't quite reach it that running with
nice in the playoffs last year in game two
their first meeting since a bouncing pu
loose in front and Matthew kachu looking
for all that back to e with the shot was off
the leg of Gregor now picked up by kachuck in
shoot and wall makes the point blank save KN
laner slammed there by kachuck Chu and wall
both have St Louis Roots part of the challenge
playing the style that they play I me they got
the playoffs to worry about it but they
have 82 games too it's a very physical
style shot fired down and still LS that's
not the guy that Carolina and Toronto saw
in rounds two and three here his cousins back
with it spins away from Tim throws it back and
bounc and cut worldwide by lost Arena and Tim
sends that down got to mention Joseph wo came
in relief of the injured Sam off in that Playoff
Series last year he had a 921 save percentage in
the three games played pretty well the trouble
in that series was Toronto scored two goals in
each of the five games for longberg that's
knocked down by Gregor picked up by Tim and
Conor Timmons has it go off stanet Gad a back
hand shot wall makes the save now mour poke
cheek there picked up by beri Le half numbers as
beri brings it up with tovaris and Marner berzi
centers it star knocks that away as Marner got
thrown down by mum here's Cousins being Lin up
by yarc turns it over to DOI DOI back for Tim
a long shot goes up backl and wide Max doy for
Robertson in shoot star the point blank save
on Nick Robertson all kind of time in the slot
rare turnover by Florida Roberton had it quite
where he wanted back lost to read in the LA shot
handled now nean takes the draw with Matthews
kicked out P it wins another one back to mour
long shot to through and went just wide K Jack SL
did as his turning attemp knocked down by kak to
mour Randon Montour backand shot kicked Away by
Riley rebound a good stop there by Wallen again
turns away H high in the air back down to the
leaf Zone as a el goes back for the skipping C
wber longberg throws down me laner xite with
a shot [__] by jordano rebound put wide by
gagovic and the bouncing pu goes to stenland he
fires it by wo and Florida takes a one- nothing
lead flicks it out and then lomber out muscles
knee Lander create the turnover opportunity but
eventally gets the St Lin on the back check
Toronto hasn't got bodies back in the right
spot just yet neander playing down low mccab was
retreating for an outlet pass that never came and
just too many bodies up four on three down by the
net Zin who's been in you mentioned Florida plays
aggressively at four lines Reinhardt sh it back
in front Parov turned away by wall he got knocked
over by Rodriguez out by Ean Larson across it goes
to kulakov kulakov back for barov to kulakov cross
he goes that Marson in shoots wall makes the
glove save four shots with Le the can rather
that 4minute power play D be back out of the box
shoot St Sav back between his TS again and this
time he hangs on so it's two of the three posts
he had up the same one twice all three and three
doar in overtime against Chicago yeah neand off
the face off plays it back across Matthews shoots
his star get a block her on that something Midway
point of the second period C brings it ahead along
with Greer and re is Gregor a quick chance and
stars a save on that don't don't overthink it
back there around the boards and get back in net
now a chance [Applause] goor Noah Gregor moves in
[Music] SC Noah Greer the dash and the
Flash and the Le tie of the game at
one Puck squeezes by gulov on the point he's
playing on his off side no one's catching
Gregor and SAR have to respect the ability
to pull this to his back end all the way
across he's going so fast so he leaves the
right post a little early and Ting that one
went post and in for the Toronto Maple leavs
nice finish that is well done no mcregor that
back Robertson picks it up Nick Robertson back
down to Gregor looks back in Fr up by KN Turn
Away by snow hard in the second period Le have
tied it up after KN came that close ging dra
believe joharz with the trener
MCC moving in MCC fires blocked by
kulak rebound still loose in front forzi
digging for it lifted high in the air by
cousins NE land winds it across the line
for Matthews Austin Matthews into that k
and shot stop by stard remains a one1 tie
on mson leaves hockey on [Music] TSN and
the shootout begins William neander is
0 for three this year being on stolar
neander stopped by the Florida net ner
fores them wide oh got a piece of it good
save in comes Lindell on wo and
he's turned away quick hands going
th000 mph over top of the puck te him
down and gets the glove out away from
body right on top of it in comes
Matthews on stolar oh hello AR do
that oh smooth P back find quickly and
star just put it shut the five fast
enough in comes Reinhard on wol shoot scores
and on the round four we go top goal scores
in the NHL right there cucumber gets right on
top of him flick no problems don't only score
CU only shootter Robertson stopped by stolar
that's Well Done by stolar Robertson put a lot
on that shot to win it for Florida in comes
Rodriguez scores and the Florida Panthers win
it regulation he is for fact the bean pot
appropriate the Boston University Terrier
would pull that off and he actually gets it
underneath the pad wall was right there and
they're just calling the players back on the a
for a second to see wait a minute make sure that
that was not double touched in it was oh H hang
on a second here it was into the pad then back
into the stick is what they're looking at and
that's what they're holding everyone for yeah
hang on get the zon off get walls back in the
dress room Mike Van Ryan's deide 22 review it's
determined that the Florida player double tap
the puck this is wild and now f are trying to
scream back into the building Noah Gregor Works
in oh my goodness did he ever that's his spot
apparently can imag he's got many shootout
attempts what a rip what a rip so facing a
loss 30 seconds ago now it's a save for
a win on Nick cousins oh wall stru can
win it for the leaes Here Comes cousins hit
the go post and re s [Music] it what again